Trump was first elected the stock market
took a tumble and the following days
however the doubt climbed to an all-time
high peter coy and the economics editor
of bloomberg businessweek magazine looks
into the surprisingly warm reception
that businesses the stock market and
investors have greeted the trump
presidency look anybody who was against
Trump would have to admit it's a bit of
a surprise with the stock market's been
so strong since he was elected the mood
has changed dramatically business
essentially is betting the Trump won't
do what he says but what exactly did
Trump say that experts believe he will
slowly walk back I'm not going to drag
us into war he's not going to start
trade wars he'll be deregulatory in sort
of a conventional Republican way which
would be good for Wall Street will be
good for the pharmaceutical industry as
far as Trump's infrastructure plan is
actually proposing a trillion dollars
worth of infrastructure spending over
ten years so this infrastructure plan is
a little different than most Trump's
advisors say the plan wouldn't raise the
deficit because the only cost would be
federal tax credits and that would be
offset by the taxes on the wages and
profits of the contractors on these
projects I think a lot of liberals had
always been urging more infrastructure
another in this odd position where they
they find themselves endorsing a trump
plan and now we have Republicans in
control of the White House the house and
the Senate a deal that should've been
done years ago finally we'll get done
the only thing bigger than Trump's
infrastructure plan are his proposed tax
cuts it's so big that even some of the
conservative organizations like the Tax
Foundation that light tax cuts are
saying it would blow a hole in a federal
budget and cause a large increase in
federal debt it's also aimed so that the
largest portion benefits go to the
richest Americans so these are the kinds
of people who'd be benefiting most from
Trump's tax cuts the theory of course is
that you cut taxes you induce for
economic activity that produces tax
revenue which pays for itself reality as
we've discovered over decades of this is
that tends not to happen it's pretty
tough to pin down how a trump presidency
will pan out just yet Trump is going to
be pulling a lot of surprise
and we just hope that we as a country
hope that they're good surprises not bad